[Music]
what is he already teaching those kids
why did luffy not say goodbye to momo
and kinemon when exactly did yamato
change her mind about the one thing that
she's been telling everyone about
throughout the entire race um oh
heartbroken
okay let's talk about the final chapter
of the wanokuni arc i am very confused
let's say about how oda sensei has
decided to wrap everything up here it's
a really strange ending to an arc that i
have enjoyed for pretty much every
single chapter since it has started i
mean wano has some of the highest highs
that one piece has to offer i'm actually
working on a full analysis of the arc
overall there is of course gear 5 and
luffy's epic clash with kaido the
unparalleled world building culture and
beauty of wano as a country and
countless fantastic characters with
fantastic story arcs that i will
genuinely miss not having around going
forward heck i'll gladly admit that
until luffy's defeat of kaido and the
end of the raid wano has been my
favorite arc in the story so far for me
personally competing easily with the
likes of an islami or even marine forts
and if you've been following this
channel at all you will know that there
is barely anything that i will feel like
talking about negatively with one piece
yes different people have different
tastes and i also just as many other
people too fall into the trap of
expecting certain things to happen that
then don't like a longer flashback for
kaido for instance but i still felt that
from a storytelling perspective and more
importantly an entertainment one wano
was a true masterpiece up to
99.8 percent
of the way really and sadly at least as
of right now it didn't really stick the
landing properly now that's not to say
that i think wano is bad now or that
this chapter in particular was terrible
or unreadable i still think wano overall
was fantastic and i have a lot of
positive things to say about today as
well for sure especially about the
goodbye between luffy law and kids the
emotional flashback and the fact that we
get to look forward to a completely new
and unexplored island after this before
we get into it a quick word from today's
sponsor space sleeper cuckoo space leap
cocoon is a freshly released space bound
mobile card game where you use an
amazing team of characters to go on
randomly generated adventures and
discover the secrets hidden in the
depths of the universe the story takes
place after a cosmic explosion has led
to the collapse of society the survivors
have gathered aboard the cocoon a
technologically advanced spaceship and
they travel the fragmented space in
search of cosmic shards to weave the
universe back together this game
combines two things i hold very dearly
personally beautiful retro pixel art and
strong furry anime girls space sleeper
can be played cross-platform and they
have even partnered up with their own
vtuber with a model inspired from the
game so make sure to download space
deeper cocoon using the link in the
description and start assembling your
own squad right now and using the codes
leap to you you get 10 free draws as
well i mean these three luffy line kit
just have the best dynamic kid always
being able to get luffy and even law to
do stupid stuff that's absolutely
hilarious and i love that law is trying
to act like all tough here as if he's
not gonna cry himself to sleep at night
for not having choppa around anymore i'm
super excited to hopefully see both of
them sooner rather than later again in
the story and i'm incredibly excited to
see where the straw hats might be going
next what bounties they've gotten and
whether we'll see a bit more of what's
going on around the world right now but
we also have to talk about why this
chapter and the ones before that made up
the epilogue of wano felt kind of off
and i'm mostly talking about the
citizens of wano here because obviously
green bull and shanks were absolutely
awesome but there are issues i have with
this chapter in particular though i will
say that there might be one explanation
that would rectify all of this and
vindicate oda sensei as the godly author
that he still is but we'll get to that
in a second first i do have some bones
to pick here sadly and before i get to
the betrayal of the century and yamato
who has become one of my favorite
characters
not joining the crew after oh that has
happened i first need to vent a little
bit again about the pacing here now i'm
really not sure if it was oda sensei
trying to get shanks into the story in
time for film rats his newfound
determination to just finish the story
in the next two or three years or if
maybe it was all just planned to go like
this from the very start but the last 10
chapters of one also felt incredibly
rushed like there were so many open plot
points and character arcs that still
needed finishing and while odasense
admittedly managed to address most of
them in a quick few panels here and
there it really didn't feel like it was
enough i mean zaro's encounter with the
grim reaper and him taking the drugs
seems to have had no consequences at
least for now
nor did all the setup for zaro having
wano heritage there was also absolutely
no moral reckoning for kaido or big mom
nor any clarity about what actually
happened to them and that's really just
to name a few things here i mean in
general having a handful of chapters to
wrap up an entire arc would be more than
enough in any other manga but in one
piece and especially for wano that
lasted an incredible four years with
many chapters focused on building up
these relationships and teasing many
mysteries it just felt so abrupt really
kaido gets hammered into the ground big
party goodbye that's kind of how it goes
and it really scares me to think about
everything that's coming next all the
awesome places and events we're about to
see during the final loft hill saga
that all of this will also feel equally
rushed when now should be the time to
actually slow down and enjoy the ride
and get all the answers to all the
mysteries that have been building up
throughout the story but let's now move
on to my bleeding heart a few of you
might remember my reaction to yamato's
very first appearance in the story
literally from the very first chapter
that yamato revealed herself to luffy i
have wanted to see her join the crew
after this hashtag yamato for nakama a
character that came out of nowhere
during the third act of wano that oda
sensei built up and gave
characterization to in just a few
chapters and that ended up as the most
awesome character that we met in all of
wano to me personally at least yamato
had everything it would take to become a
great straw hat for the final part of
the story a tragic backstory incredible
strength fantastic character design a
major character flaw for luffy dissolve
being uber attached to the persona of
odin and of course a dream the dream to
finally leave moano the place where she
had been captive all her life become a
pirate and see the world together with
luffy ace's little brother in fact
yamato said this so often that i got
worried oda sensei might pull the brakes
on this the last second though i didn't
want to believe it i mean really every
second line or so that yamato had was
basically i'm going to set sail with
luffy and become a pirate she sent it to
luffy to momo to kaido to luffy again to
the straw hats
this
was her thing her dream and so it felt
like yamato was going to be like this
embodiment of luffy's triumph in wano on
board of the sunny an eccentric fun and
strong female character for the crew who
is worshipping and striving to be like
her idol odin and now she suddenly wants
to stay behind and travel wanna first
the place that she wanted to leave more
than anything else like when did this
change of heart happen please was it in
this conversation with luffy that she
apparently had why did oda not show this
to us did luffy entrust her with like a
special mission or something but it
feels so very unlike luffy to keep
someone from being free and living their
dream don't you think and if yamato was
not introduced to become a straw hat
after all this
what please was the point of her
character because becoming a straw hat
very much felt like the point throughout
the raids really if this is it for
yamato and we just see her again for the
final battle when pluton is released why
introduce her in the first place i'm so
confused and
sad about this really what was the point
of waiting so long with her introduction
and all these scenes focusing on her
wanting to set out to see with luffy i
mean if i didn't know any better i would
just say that oda sensei suddenly just
changed his mind about her character
last second here the entire goodbye
scene at the port where luffy offers to
pick up yamato momo and kinemon whenever
they wanna join the crew
it feels a lot like another jimbei
situation really it does sound like they
will join at some point but remember one
piece is in its final arc and is trying
to wrap up in two or three years
so when exactly is this supposed to
happen and will it really matter if it's
only for a couple of chapters for the
final battle and i guess since we're on
that topic right now what exactly was
the plan for carrots and why didn't she
get a goodbye either or is she actually
waiting on board of the ship honestly i
feel like at this point the strats have
to at least leave with one member after
the longest arc in one piece history
like please then there is also marco who
had come to fight side by side with the
crew who risked his life for luffy what
exactly happened to him after the
funeral of izo did the crew say goodbye
to him and what is he gonna do next oh
boy and then there's of course
the weirdest part of this entire chapter
hiyori's bizarre line to the citizens of
wano in the reenactment of the raid of
onigashima which by the way let's be
real is kind of strange that they
already have one week after the battle
ended
but whatever hiori who apparently plays
herself here says the line the citizens
have been waiting for which apparently
is not wano is free or the tyrant has
been defeated but that the kurozumi are
born to burn a cheeky little twist on
the odin was born to borderline but more
importantly a really strange and hateful
takeaway from all that has happened to
wano like what the i actually didn't
have access to the original japanese
version of this line but if it's even
remotely accurately translated this is
some dark stuff right here like really
your moral of the story and everything
that has happened is that people should
be burned for the clan they were born
into it's such a strange messaging for a
story that keeps telling us over and
over again that discrimination is bad
that a person isn't bound and their fate
isn't determined by the family or race
that they're born into no matter if it's
dophian corazon sanji being a vinsmoke
robin being from o'hara the fishman
and so on and so forth the entire moral
of one piece so far is the exact
opposite of what you hori is saying here
pretty much so why did oda put it in
here clearly it's not his personal view
of things so the only explanation i have
is that he is portraying the people of
wano including hiyori as having learned
nothing from their suffering of the last
20 years or so instead being all
vengeful and stuff it was exactly this
generalization and hatred of someone's
heritage that led to the endless cycle
of hatred in the country in the first
place the kudozumi plotting against
everyone else and everyone plotting
against the kurozumi so why this dark
twist at the end of wano when everyone
should have changed their views and be a
more open and inclusive country instead
wanos borders stay closed and the people
fall back into the same discrimination
as before
what it almost feels like wano as an arc
isn't quite over yet yamato has to stay
behind for some reason borders closed
and even though the country has been
freed from tyranny for now hatred and
discrimination is still part of everyday
life and culture in wano only that of
course mono is over except
what if it isn't the narrator literally
tells us that we're taking a little
break and that will be back in one o
soon so let's say the straw hats go on
like a mini adventure maybe a very short
interlude arc let's sphinx island maybe
to visit ace's grave and then come back
to pick up yamato and resolve like some
small conflict in the country for
example there's the idea that toko might
be a kurozumi so that might be a factor
so please let's not burn toko and so if
that were the case and we're going back
to wano and a very short fourth act very
soon i would drop any criticism i've
shared here today and just bow before
oda sensei's picture i guess we'll just
have to wait and see or maybe you've
already forgotten all the other
questions and open mysteries that we
still need answers to before one piece
ends well in that case you can refresh
your knowledge of all open questions
with this video right here